but up to five minutes to talk about
whatever you want anything anything huh
okay
[Music]
let's do
let's talk about
suicide I know it's a different name to
talk about but I lost my brother to
suicide in 2010 and
I just recently have been more open
about it
[Applause]
I feel like there's a lot of light to be
shed on suicide prevention and signs
depression
and excepting those that have
depression or
place
I'd like to
hopefully shed light someday on that
topic I know a lot of veterans are
struggling with it and yeah you know I
just feel like it's not talked about
enough it's like a subject that people
are afraid to talk about either because
they're depressed themselves or they're
embarrassed that a loved one took their
life or
maybe they don't understand or maybe
they feel I know I've heard a lot of
times people say are you you think your
brother was selfish or
yeah selfish and there was a time where
I did but you know it's not a selfish
thing to do think necessarily
[Applause]
I just that's the whole thing we don't
know exactly that's why the light needs
to be shed and
it'd be good too I think little
communities within our community fit
together and you know if you're
struggling with depression just talk
about it like we need more peer to peer
support
I feel like
there's a lot of lonely people out there
you don't have an out not that my
brother was lonely it was it was a
different situation but
yeah I guess that's my my topic I have a
lot of friends that have like that are
so that are so like powerless to men
when it comes to like I don't know even
like them talking about them they just
feel they like lose themselves because
they because I feel like men have just
this huge influence on them for like
many reasons it's from like like how
they see them or how they make them feel
and I think that's depressing because
women deserve so much better like and I
think
I don't like him I don't like this is my
boyfriend for that to be no it's
important for women to just love woman
and support other woman I think that's
super good and I'm glad that like
everything's turning and we're becoming
stronger people because it's super
important
I'd like to bring down we're buddies
awareness you know legalize marijuana
legalized CBD it really helps people
with disabilities I'm legally blind and
I have glaucoma if it wasn't for my
medication I wouldn't be able to do
simple tasks during the day it would be
very very difficult for me to even be
part of normal society but I didn't have
my medications eyedrops are nice and
everything but we have to realize that
with standard medication you still have
a lot of drawbacks and people don't see
that I just want people to be more aware
that marijuana grows from the ground it
doesn't I don't have to you know make it
chemically I don't have to make it in a
plant or somewhere or in a laboratory I
can grow it myself you can grow it
yourself it's a wonderful form of
medicine that's standardly natural and I
just want to bring that to everybody's
attention thank you for letting me do
that so in 2016
lost I think it was nearly 26 percent or
30 percent of our coral reefs and I
think that we should do more in
protecting our wildlife and our climate
so for example maybe every day you can
stop and think about how much waste
you're producing so do you really need
that straw when you drink a cup of coke
or do you really need that excess
packaging plastic bag so it would be
really great if you know sometimes you
might think that one you're just one
person it doesn't really change that
much in the whole scheme of things but
the reality is if you do a small thing
it will accumulate in your lifetime and
also maybe you'd inspire people to do
the same and it will be a huge domino
effect right now we have other resources
to help save our planet and it's not
something we can't do but it's just a
will to do it I guess
thanks for watching another episode if
you haven't already it would mean a lot
if you subscribe to my channel like this
video share it a couple episodes of
friends and help support my project
thank you
[Music]